now let's go back to Washington DC nor
is there where she talked to some of the
nation's top CEOs about the need for tax
reform and there is a new plan being
floated in Congress this morning Nora
that's right good morning to you Gail
that's right two high-profile
Republicans have a tentative plan for
tax cut legislation senators bob corker
and pat toomey agreed to an outline that
would add 1.5 trillion dollars to the
debt over the next 10 years they believe
economic growth would offset all of the
red ink tax cuts without spending
reductions go against traditional GOP
principles and yesterday we spoke to two
of the country's top ceos Jamie Dimon of
JPMorgan Chase and IBM's Ginni Rometty
about tax reform I think everybody knows
that our tax code is overly complex but
how is it uncompetitive
well it's uncompetitive in a few ways
but I think in addition to being over
complex just give it a little
perspective it's been 30 years since
there's been really major tax reform and
if any of us think back 30 years no cell
phone no internet so I mean that should
just tell you about something about how
out of date it is